It's yours now. What is? The
darksaber, it belongs to you
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is
going to be my new mandalorian video for
the darksaber the throne of mandalore and the new
mandalore leader of their people if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
episodes i will be doing mandalorian videos and
videos for all the star wars series while we wait
for them to get here there will be new star wars
episodes during 2021 i'm going to keep that disney
plus giveaway for memberships open all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave all your
predictions for mandalorian season 3 on the video
so obviously careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the mandalorian so far
but during the mandalorian season 2 episode
8 finale mandalorian saves grogu from moff
gideon and in the process they have their
full-blown best scar spear versus darksaber
fight that they've been hyping up all season
since the ahsoka tano episode it was a really
solid fight scene i love the choreography i also
felt like it was a good call back to his fight as
oberyn martell versus the mountain during game of
thrones thankfully this time he wore a helmet but
in the course of their fight mando beats moff
gideon and without thinking twice disarms them
takes the dark saber and then marches into the
bridge the whole reason why he walks into the
bridge like a champion with it activated is
just because he's trying to use it to make
sure moff gideon doesn't turn and run off he's not
trying to be over dramatic or anything like that
as we've learned there are a lot of things that he
just does not know about the grander mythology of
the star wars universe he doesn't know a lot
about the jedi and seemingly does not know a
lot about the history or the lore or the rules of
the darksaber its symbolic significance to their
people so he has no idea what's going on when Bo
Katan gets all pissed off at him he tries to give
it to her she refuses it then moff gideon launches
into another villain monologue giancarlo esposito
is so good at doing those about why he can't
just give her the darksaber it has to be won
and not earned otherwise the new mandalore the
new ruler of their people would be viewed as a
pretender to the throne and they'd never be able
to get anything done nobody would ever listen to
them there are a lot of you that are asking about
some contradictory scenes from canonical clone
wars and star wars rebels episodes i'll address
that during the video too because literally people
give it from one person to another during those
series but during the mandalorian series Bo Katan
wants to use the darksaber as a symbol to rally
all the mandalorians in the galaxy to her banner
and her plan is to then arm them with ships and
weapons stolen from the empire to defeat grand
admiral thrawn moff gideon's forces and retake the
planet mandalore take back all the other things
that the empire stole from them during the great
purge one of the really big things that they talk
about during season one is the best scar that
was stolen from them now you have to imagine
mountains and mountains of baskar because this
is an entire planet's resources per jon favreau's
heavy infantry mandalorian character fun fact
he was actually playing someone related to the
animated clone wars mandalorian character that he
played years ago for dave filoni this guy on the
series is called paz vizsla his other character
was one of the previous wielders of the darksaber
his name was pre vizsla from the death watch
mandalorians the same mandalorians that rescued
din djarin during the clone wars when he was a
foundling you can thank dave filoni for building
all these easter eggs and connections across the
different eras of the shows but before they can
deal with the problem of the darksaber in the new
mandalore the dark troopers attack luke skywalker
comes and grogu leaves with him so mando and
everyone else end things with this still hanging
in the air waiting to be resolved at some point
during mandalorian season 3. so as of right now
the mandalorian character din jaron is effectively
the new mandalore the new ruler of their entire
people by rights the new king of mandalore his
claim to the best scar throne is legitimized by
him winning the darksaber in combat to make a
star trek reference the mandalorians within the
star wars universe are kind of like klingons
in that their honor their rules their customs
are very very important to them and bokutan's not
going to violate that she's not going to suddenly
break their rules because she knows that the
other mandalorians around the galaxy will find
out what she did and kick her off the throne so
it'd completely undermine everything that she's
trying to do so early prediction mando will still
have the darksaber when season 3 picks up after
a short time jump just because of the way the
timeline is going to work with the book of boba
fett episodes the events of the mandalorian season
3 episodes will pick up after the end of the book
of boba fett episodes but through circumstance not
by choice mando will be viewed symbolically as the
new mandalore and that's how the other regular
mandalorians around the galaxy will start talking
about him when they hear what happened on moff
gideon's ship it's the same thing that happened
to luke skywalker canonically after he blew
up quote-unquote the first death star the myth
of luke skywalker started to spread around the
galaxy so think about the legends that people are
going to start spinning about mando even though he
doesn't care about any of that stuff right now Bo
Katan will probably try to spin what happened here
on moff gideon ship to their advantage and use
mando with the darksaber as a symbol to rally more
of their people to join the fight she's trying to
get all the ships and weapons that she can and
the better story she tells the better this story
sounds the faster that will happen but the way
they leave things at least in mando's eyes she's
still the one in charge calling all the shots he
has no interest in being the king of mandalorians
he only agreed to join her in exchange for her
helping rescue grogu that's what he said to her
in that bar you can have anything you want i'll do
whatever you want just help me rescue the kid so
he's become that prototypical mono myth hero like
you talk about joseph campbell's hero's journey
the exact same arc is luke skywalker during the
original trilogy luke skywalker starts out as this
normal kid so he thinks obi-wan kenobi gives him
anakin skywalker's lightsaber and asks him to come
to alderaan with him and join the war he refuses
the hero's call which is part of the joseph
campbell hero's journey i can't go have a star war
with you i have to get ready for the harvest i'm
a moisture farmer cut to later in the movie he's
training as a jedi and he's answered the hero's
call earlier on the show mando refused bo katan's
first call to action the first heroes call i have
to get grogu to the jedi now he's done that and
he's agreed to join her cause answering the call
so in the same way that the myth of luke skywalker
spread around the galaxy after the first death
star was blown up this hero of the rebellion
dealing the empire this crushing blow the same
type of story will probably spread about mando
in the darksaber the myth of this new mandalore
uniting their people the real elephant in the
room that a lot of you have asked about though
is that during star wars rebels in the clone
wars episodes which are canon to official star
wars the dark saber is given to Bo Katan and it
doesn't seem like it causes any problems so why
suddenly are there all these rules about it now
on the mandalorian series during the clone wars
darth maul wins it through combat from pre-vizsla
then uses it to take control of mandalore with
his shadow collective crime syndicate eventually
he takes the darksaber back to dathomir where it
stays until the events of star wars rebels ezra
bridger and sabine wren wind up stealing it then
sabine wren eventually gives the darksaber to
bo katan at the end of that series then the way
moff gideon explained it to mando when they were
in the cell here he got it from her and per the
rules he must have defeated her in combat somehow
now mando has it because he defeated moff gideon
but why can't he give it to bo katan now if it
was given to her by sabine during rebels and just
based on what jon favreau and dave filoni have
been doing adapting the animated characters and
their stories to live action i think what they've
done is they've just changed a few minor details
in service of more dramatic storytelling and
twists to complicate the relationships between
the characters in a more adult way whereas
the animated shows that dave filoni made were
intended for a younger audience so i think this
is them just kind of recontextualizing some of
their earlier work it's the same thing with george
lucas he did that all the time like why did luke
and leia share that really awkward really weird
brother-sister kiss during empire strikes back the
real explanation for that is because during empire
strikes back he had not yet decided to write the
story of them being brother and sister originally
he wanted to have a love triangle between those
three characters but then by the time he got
ready to write the story of return of the jedi he
changed his mind and decided to make luke and leia
secretly brother and sister so i think it's one of
those things where you just have dave filoni and
jon favreau sort of changing some details about
their earlier stories just a little bit in the
service of dramatic storytelling and just in terms
of character relationships on the mandalorian
live-action series i don't know if they have any
kind of special arc planned for Bo Katan and mando
together they do seem like they had some chemistry
in their scenes together but that's just katie
sakhoff and pedro pascal being really amazing
actors when you think about the way the star wars
movies treated han solo in princess leia there
was just a little bit of that going on in the
background their actual relationship didn't really
officially begin until after the events of return
of the jedi i don't really have any expectations
for that and it's not really what the show is
about right now it's really about this big war
with grand admiral thrawn that they're building
up to but they're going to be working together a
lot during season 3 just because mando is now kind
of working for her there have been rumors of them
doing a one-off mini-series for Bo Katan like
the book of Bo Katan so i am kind of wondering
now if when we get to our big thrawn crossover
they'll call that the book of thrawn but i'll
do more videos as we get more details about that
but what's happening next is there's going to be
a special bonus episode of the mandalorian season
2 that'll drop on christmas day this friday so i
will do a video for that and if there's anything
special or big questions or things you want me to
do videos about just let me know in the comments
everyone click here for my full mandalorian luke
skywalker video and all my episode videos and
click here to learn what's going on with the book
of boba fett spin-off series thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe this is the way!